um it's too much bananana you shouldn't
be able to do this with a dessert this
is a bad sign what is better than one
banana three bananas and why I feel like
they invented business in NASA oh it
tastes like really really really dense
banana bread oh good excuse me please
explain how you got three bananas in
here
biological [ __ ] Festa oh it sounds like
a coconut pie hey whoo what are we got
here oh god they're like giant dinner
Minh I don't really like coconut by just
candy but this is this is pretty good
I've never seen a candy before that like
warned you on the bag explicitly like
brush your teeth these are good for your
teeth apparently I'm gonna assume that's
what that little happy tooth means on
the back of it literally don't use any
coconut whatsoever look if you didn't
have coconut on the bag that's fine this
is it's sweeter than sugar bees it's a
you know a biscuit but peace no time
please [ __ ] I'm all up in this [ __ ]
that's better than the kick-out I do
like the wafers though because I'm a
texture person and I like the crunchy
but imagine the crunch is nice not as
delicious yeah
really like just wafers with chocolate
yeah there's nothing you can pop up with
this side Shaboom sands and mayo our
mellow I've given all purpose right
it says friend boa so which i think
means strawberry looks like plastic so
it's probably pretty good candid three
two one oh my good game over
this is gonna pull out my cabinet I
think he could take a bullet like just
the right amount of artificial and very
gooey it has some extra tool has a
little little Samba to it what I'm
saying look some of this Kylie do it
eat it was nice kidding you're amazing
candy Brazil and um no I feel like it
could conquer the world with all the
sugar running for my feet